I frankly don't think you should be here
I am not qualified to deliver I know
Andy is not qualified to deliver I could
do it oh my god we are we're matching we
kind of are matching in many ways yeah
yeah that's the only way we met hard to
tell us apart yeah yeah you look
gorgeous how do you feel horrible yeah
oh my god I have to pee right now and I
just pee do I oh my god I just peed and
I just walked from the dressing room
here and I was like I have to I have to
pee again yeah I'm tired everything
hurts this couch is really uncomfortable
to the best stuff I told you that well
first of all no no one has it almost
looks like your jacket
wait a minute such a pervert that I've
enjoyed that no but I mean you know my
wife we have two children and when she
was in the past the eight months she was
like oh my god let's have this baby now
now now and that's how much you must be
feeling that yeah I'm definitely I'm
definitely that way every day I'm like I
can do one thing a day and this movie
were supposed to come out in April and
then they pushed it and I was like oh so
all the press has been now and and and
thank God because it's a number one
movie in America and number one comedy
yeah I'm very excited about it but for
you yeah it's exciting except that I'm
exhausted
yeah so I do one thing today you're it
today
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah he's you said that was so much joy
no I do one thing today in your I can't
breathe we're gonna get you through this
don't you worry about it first of all
this must be weird for you because for
years the tabloids have been falsely
reporting yeah Eva Longoria is pregnant
Eva Longoria pregnant and they're always
wrong yeah well no what happened was my
husband we found out we were pregnant
and of course we didn't want to tell
anybody until it's like a healthy time
to say and and I was like my husband was
like how are we gonna hide it and I said
tabloids every month I'm pregnant for
the past 20 years I eat a burger and
it's like Eva's pregnant and I eat a
crouton baby understand how babies are
made
you don't get them from burgers no it's
like I've been on baby bump watch for 20
years and then fine I was like I was
telling my husband it's fine because
they're gonna say it anyway and then the
tablets came out and they're like Eva's
fat gained so much weight
mistre and I was like I'm glad that's
how they got it out of you it's the baby
I mean the baby must be kicking a lot
now right he's beyond kicking he's like
he's like doing flamenco on my bladder
right yeah he's like he's like moves and
does all it's like before it was kicking
and I was like oh that's so cute now I'm
like yeah yeah now it's like Robert De
Niro in Raging Bull just in the way and
everything around everything yeah did
the music backstage because I you know
sometimes babies hear music and they
yeah and they they get sued there you
can actually in the womb feel that they
calm down a little bit you know my
husband and I have this app it's called
the bump and it was like oh your baby
can hear now so you should start singing
to them cuz it soothes the baby and I'm
Michael I don't notice thing well why do
I have to sing and so now I'm really
stressed out are you doing it are you
doing any singing for them no I mean
please there's an unborn baby here in
your screaming oh oh did you sense
anything there no totally creeped out
yeah baby it's not gonna come out now
just staying in here people away that
possibly guy and maybe woman goes away
are you getting my wife when I met her
it was a vegetarian and we get married
she gets pregnant and then I took her
out one night while she was pregnant and
she I was eating a hamburger a hamburger
and she said can I have one bite
uh-huh and I was like yeah and she took
it and she pushed it all into her face
and was never a vegetarian again really
no yeah solve that problem
[Laughter]
you